[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hi everyone and welcome to day 3 for
games sports play for all event we are
gonna be raising money for black lives
matter today as well as Direct Relief to
support covert efforts joining me today
we've got a lot of Pierce it's just like
80 Bunch at one point up and today oh
yeah hi how's it going
we have a slight little delay as our
vmix
is like figuring itself out but we're
gonna be playing some minecraft the
donation link up below on the screen
right now wait we're trying to do the
point down that I'm running very
commands that I read I'd commit to the
bit I don't know I guess it's cuz I'm
British and I don't know the Brady Bunch
was never really a thing for us so where
are you going okay I'm ready to cause
mischief oh look how cool you look damn
to see you just with regular old Steve I
just want to be Steve man look at it I
got it
also I'm gonna be piped Steve as a combo
they all play the same basically they
just played a bunch of this game but
it's my first time playing on xbox so
it's gonna take me a little while to
figure out how everything works but
we'll get there I'm gonna choose a
mission guys we're going to the creeper
woods already good
oh yes would I like to should tell you
yeah he'd see me subtly tab over there
yes alright let's do it yeah so this is
basically Tam if you didn't know it's
like Diablo but really easy but also
minecraft if that makes sense
it's Diablo lights baby's first Diablo
I am the gateway to Diablo pretty much
it's how they get you
is from this to straight-up devil
dungeon gameplay going to be getting
real into Diablo and gateway drugs hell
yeah dude
you know we come in and we find stuff
that's pretty much how it works like
someone in the GameSpot chat said they
should be playing some Final Fantasy 7
remake not minecraft dungeons ok dad I
mean alright maybe maybe if you stay
tuned to play for all programming we
will end up playing Final Fantasy 7 with
a very special get up no only minecraft
dungeons like honestly when we were
talking about what to play and you were
suggesting games and then you suggested
this one and this has completely been
off my radar
I haven't played minecraft in a very
long time and then we were doing stuff
yesterday like troubleshooting and
setting up for the stream and I played
some ores like dams is one Chilika
Lagoon yeah it's more fun than I expect
it to be honest for something so simple
like and they're all like boss fights
that get pretty hard and I like the RPG
mechanics it's so it's alright you know
it's alright I feel like these micro on
the same I'm an absolute goon and I
forgot to turn off my notifications so
[Music]
that you both have uneven game escola
and it is gusting this is Microsoft
Studios and 343 industries we played
halo Anniversary Collection the other
day together and it's like hey you
walked here's one point I know it's so
bad I know I remember so I used to
I in the 360 days especially like I was
super into gamerscore
you wouldn't actually believe that by
looking at my current gaming school
because it's actually quite low but I
would be very into trying to get as many
as I could and then what now I'm
predominantly like a ps4 player and the
trophy system to me still doesn't make
sense so I don't think I don't think any
of them have a real like I mean
ultimately pointless but I feel like I
have a pretty healthy relationship with
achievements where oh we got to go back
I will just I don't like hunt for them
but if I like a game and I want to get
more time out of it I'll look through
the list for the things that fight seem
fun or seem easy and then go for them
yeah so it's yeah I always every time I
get a new game I always look at the
trophies or achievements and just kind
of see what's attainable
so Nicole oil I'm looking through now
it's actually way easier than original
persona 5 because they got rid of a
bunch of like the crummy trophies that
involved like maxing up everyone's
social rank or completing the persona
confidant was the real you not do that
with absolutely everyone you can't rank
you I think because it gives you you had
to you had to min/max the crap out of it
in turn because you also had to rank up
all of your social stats mm-hmm Dante
Nero says trophies are like Funko's fun
to see but that's it yeah it's nice Xbox
has a diamond achievements if I ever get
one of those but I did just hit 75,000
earlier this week which was cool but
like I said try not to actually go for
them too hard because I feel like I mean
it's just when you work in games media
as well like something I mostly get PC
codes so I mostly tend to be playing
things on PC for reviews or whatever
sometimes it's PlayStation sometimes
it's Xbox is just like no sense and that
kind of loyalty
really yeah oh I was coming anymore I
know on my blade I'm out of arrows so
that's the huge bummer to everyone in my
chat is why I put the link one and
donate in the description here I imagine
it is one game sports chat also
donations so thank you to Georgia
Briscoe for five dollars much
appreciated
we are raising money that war black
lives matter and also covert relief in
partnership with Derek relief so
originally we were doing it just for Co
vid relief to help health care workers
out by in Maya what's been happening
recently we decided it was necessary for
us to also raise money for black lives
matter and so it's kind of look at your
effort and so you'll see that's why
you'll see a couple of links down there
because you didn't go sit over the
weekend oh I did I did a stream for the
of this very game that's how I play too
much for the Minnesota freedom fund them
planning to do some more just as much as
I can need right now
I keep worrying about not to get real
bleak but um the second wave of Cova due
to all the protests this is like yeah
yeah make sure that we're also still
considering raising money for the
hospitals to facilitate those yeah Wow
for important causes it's
I mean like in time like from the UK -
it's weird that all of this is going on
in the country that we don't like we're
not from here but like tell me about its
home you want to you want to help
because it's on your doorstep - but I
think that's why I'm gonna go about
raising money for directly - is that the
helping health care workers all over the
world
yeah yes feel very global I'm just gonna
update my phone how do i how do i change
my weapon is it to change like you're a
good donors map oh this is so different
don't is amazing a lot of damage scared
me so that kind of wicked yo Jimmy you
know an old sword no oh my god I've
absolutely been done okay have you done
wait are we being attacked so so I
picked up I know I got absolutely done
by spider I I picked up some juice
picked up some TNT no no but then the
spider that caught me in his trap in his
web so basically like if I'm going down
you're coming with me spiders do be like
that as an Australian let me tell you
why this yeah you know what I'm kind of
sad that England no the UK doesn't have
like a distinctive animal threat if
you're not I'm saying cuz like like it
has like spiders yeah we've just got
some snakes feels like
like right I think I feel like yeah but
not they're not like a persistent threat
no I mean I don't think it's probably I
don't feel like there's something you
should say I kind of I feel like they
should be the people of UK on notice if
you're not careful like I said badges
are really scary yeah yeah that's true
I've never seen a badger in my life
Canada's probably nice house yeah that
was it Mousa next level like just oh my
gosh just so big I remember going to
earlier actually Alanna were you on that
trick for arkham origins in like 2013 no
to Montreal
no I would have still been working in
the Australian games industry back then
and we media very few people anywhere I
thought I met you there definitely
remember meeting an Australian lady who
was blond no I remember going on that
trip and the PR promised me like oh my
god when you when you go to Canada
you'll think this is I can't believe I
believe this he was like when you go
through the border you'll be allowed to
take a picture with a Mountie and maybe
a moose oh so excited and then yeah I
every time every time I've ever been to
Montreal for video game stuff it is this
really weird experience of and I need to
wait for my help pushing to come back of
them being like why are you here you're
like
see a video game and they're like what
video game I'm like it hasn't been
announced yet and they're like well you
have to tell us and like I that would be
breaking NDA
yeah you talk you don't have a choice so
basically like you just have a leak
unannounced games to the Montreal
security every time you have a go that
is seeing anything
I remember saying pong - there's no way
this person's gonna care or check and
like yeah watchdogs - before that got
announced and just like really want to
lie to immigration and I feel like
immigration surpasses my NDA yeah
immigration immigration definitely
Trump's each Gitmo I think so
another donation we've got from sure Oh
show Ryu King which is a lovely a user
name Thank You Allah no that's on
fatality flat out like a lizard drinking
thank you that means I assume it's
pretty Australian thing to say go to bed
yes
my family's usually awake at 3 p.m. oh I
thought you meant like Australia yeah
it's the same way we have folks in the
Australian office and we 3 p.m. is
pretty much when you see them along on
yeah it's a weird thing to like you guys
also be implement country I feel like
every day no matter what even if I don't
talk to my family and I'm in any given
day I am actively always aware of what
time they're awake always yeah every
single time oh yeah
my mom has been surprising me lately she
been texting me at like midnight which
for her
it's very strange like she falls asleep
it about man oh you my the way around
yeah so midnight midnight there is 4
p.m. here we nailed it that checks out
so - huh my mum my mother and my sister
are trapped in Pakistan so and then my
other brother and my dad are in England
so I'm like juggling two time zones how
are they trapped there what happened
so they went over for to Pakistan and
then the covert stuff happened and they
weren't allowed to fly back no way ok so
I was very much in the same boat oh
there we go hmm I never mind I think
about thinking about everything's fine
we're gonna tasty bone
hell yeah dude look like a tasty bone my
YouTube chats currently just talking
about moose very nice enchantment I'm
sad about Dragon Age now man I also got
the taste
is it so if I open that chest do you
guys get that stuff too or is it just me
oh wow oh wow wait I'm making the
donations just you got two anonymous
donations one for $500 and another for
$1,000 oh thank you
Audrey on anonymous donor thank you so
much thank you this is an anonymous
person not the group Anonymous thank you
so much that money is going to black
lives matter and Direct Relief and it
will be crucial for both causes yeah
that's awesome thank you see know a busy
man who says happy that you're safe
Ilana and doing these charity streams
keep on rockin oh thank you yeah I
totally am safe it's um definitely like
a loads of helicopters and and sirens in
my area all the time it's virtually all
night but it's weird because I know that
I'm completely safe it's just like a
very tense environment even yeah at
night but I I am yeah absolutely totally
fine okay let's good gonna soggy swamp
that's what I'm gonna suggest everybody
ready let's do it
surprisingly building I think it's the
music - I could just feel I'm sorry I'm
an inherently very anxious person we all
know this
well talked about it thank you for that
Maude sorry for the spam chat about my
bad not that I did it but it still
happened everyone I'd like you to say
hello to my wolf this part is mine too
as part of my Armour how did you get
yeah gives me it gives me a pet back you
got so cool so fast this is mine oh I'm
gonna be the best tamer of the group I
just got a new dude oh they've given it
to you at least ahead of time this time
yeah which is weird 9 p.m. is like way
later than normal I feel like they're
gonna change them but your wolf and your
fire were just ridiculous right employee
you have one yeah very cool very cool
I got him because I traded some emeralds
for a random box from the blacksmith so
yeah that's all you can use that also
emeralds are the best and you want them
official it's good stuff great stuff
I love how it's constantly telling you
where the next Waypoint is you kind of
kind of get lost so it is so what a
helpful but look like again this game is
just really easy it's just very yeah
simple
yeah book but I do like the RPG
decision-making and like choosing which
enchantment you want for your weapons
and stuff like it's not that it feels
like completely mindless but it is it is
chill I'm into it I feel like it's a
good game to stream question from
GameSpot chat you guys still playing
Animal Crossing a lot so I I started
playing it I lined up a series of game
themed present deliveries that was doing
for a bit so good was like that so III
would get a pebble and then I'd find a
black postcard and then I'll include the
description for the pebble from
blood-borne and send office like
postcard and then I included as much as
possible the description of the pink
flamingo as a objective objective power
from control and sent that over so it's
like that kind of stuff so I had like
six or seven of them I sent them all
mostly pallucci could be honest 7
reviewed which was like 60 hours in two
days yeah yeah by the time I was done I
was just like the world has moved on I'm
not interested this anymore I missed a
whole event and I was like and there's
just enough annoying things and playing
it I'm like yeah it's like very soothing
that I understand why do people like it
but I find it quite a lot of the time
honestly
ya know it's a great game for the most
part I did make a video about all the
annoying things in Animal Crossing but I
kind of kept playing because I'm just at
a point where all I'm doing is waiting
for more DIYs and more items and it's
just kind of not enough yeah so I still
play occasionally because I really
wanted to put like a proper to up on my
channel of when it's finished but I've
just been waiting for on on statues and
I kind of got to the point where I'm
like there's no point waiting anymore
because this could take months
oh yeah oh the right thumbstick and then
you can pick while you're doing that I'm
just gonna read out a couple more
Liam Graham donate their clothes thank
you so much and Draya Woods donated $50
and said cannot stay in chap I wanted to
make sure I don't know it keep up the
good work thank you so much thank you
thank you sir good cause everyone's
doing anything can I donate please tweet
out some links yes yeah what's your you
guys trying to make we know we don't
really have a goal like we just want to
as much as possible I think like every I
think the thinkin is every pairwise
going on here
every penny I don't put into big idiot
yeah so people walking people watching
that's two links at the bombs there one
is black lives matters supporting that
cause and the other one is for Co vid 19
relief with Deric relief please donate
generously
obviously if donating to one also helps
the other because black communities
right now are adversely affect and
disproportionately affected by 19 so you
are helping wherever you put your money
on this bein and I've got gold oh I got
some daggers you can see the black lives
matter
donations can't you yeah I'm on the page
I'm just trying to figure out where they
where the individual donations are I
have a cumulative total by don't have
like individual ones right now I only
you should be able to so black lives
matter isn't on top five so we had to
set up something else
okay so we've arranged it so executive
producer Chris Bowman it's just gonna
down a send me updates because you have
to download a file each time you want an
update so firstly shout-out to Chris
thank you for doing that and we've got
donations from Katherine Owen Owen there
for hunt dollars thank you so much jacob
macaw and from the GameSpot discord in
various other place others and we've got
Evan I'm gonna make sure I try to get
this name right pill Nick $50 thank you
so much and our very own Randolph friend
$25.00 thank you so much thank you
that's what we know notice another
synchronized thing between YouTube
we might be the same person I'm not sure
yeah but like from from two different
continents yeah brought together by
video games to San Francisco for a bit
amen la no we lived in the West Cape
yeah we did that was um that was when
Tam and I came over for or even working
on that watch yeah we're working on an
overwatch League project and so it kind
of ran into III so we were here for like
six weeks awesome animated and immense
lemon Benjamin lemon and mist and oven
so we would give like six weeks and we
hung out almost yeah how do you guys
like I like it la I think it's kind of
weird because right now I've been
indoors for so long I don't know where
in the world it feels like I mean it
took me very look okay you still live in
San Francisco until I kind of get to
know the city yeah it's very European in
terms of how people acting sensibilities
and stuff it's really yeah it's more so
I think it's maybe cuz I spent so long
in London right that it's are you
hitting my dog great you kicked my dog
yeah
yeah for me it doesn't quite feel like
home yeah and that's because I'm still
quite new here only irony is I think I
just reached the stage where I was like
okay I'm gonna start exploring to try
and get a good grasp of the place and
then all this stuff happens I was like
okay maybe not yeah so I always feel
like yeah I feel like I call San
Francisco a city that I walked in not a
city I lived in right he's like all I
really did but it's also cuz it's warm
right so it's more of parallel to home
like it's really sunny here today yeah I
feel like a difference for us yeah like
even even though it's foggy here it's
still miles better than London so it
feels like it's not exaggerated it's
really that terrible I think things have
changed recently like it's not that gray
all the time I think it's just because
London is a very gray City the buildings
and stuff especially like ice Canary
Wharf and that is just gray like every
single building is right that is the
colour scheme but in in the UK the I'm
gonna seem global warming but it's
really warm like 27
sometimes it was 20 something other day
how people are freaking you know pretty
good I like that I mean yeah the main
thing is that like we don't have the
infrastructure there to coke boys I have
a hot weather really hot weather already
cold weather
San Francisco same it gets really hot in
September and everyone just kind of
melts because for it at all yeah
my favorite thing about London and
weather is Londoners are so eager to
have hot weather that even the slightest
chance the slightest sign of it they go
from shorts on fully everyone and the
thing is like they never learned the
lesson that it's not gonna last and it's
probably just like a momentary thing so
like in the morning you'll see
everyone's walking to work in like
shorts and sunglasses and then by the
afternoon it's pouring with rain and
everyone looks like it's cold but in the
morning that can be really warm and it's
just like like I go to a park on a
weekend or whatever and be fine until
I'm down until some quick show yeah
Clark Clark J Clark G Joseph Kent frock
Joseph Kent donated $50 and said hi
games on Ilana along - thank you for
these Harry streams that let those of us
who aren't near places that have
protests contribute it helps we feel
somewhat useful to the cause to be able
to donate thank you so much sort of
thing where I'm not protesting at all
because I'm you know compromise have had
pneumonia I just feel like I really
can't
and it's been oh this fights actually
pretty tough you guys just Eric so I'm
just trying to do everything else that I
possibly can and I feel like a lot of
other people you know people who are at
risk of getting very
just try to do the same way you can yeah
like really levels up I am gonna Oh God
okay following me I think I almost died
but then alright
I'm kind of back back hang out back yeah
everything is fine can can can we drop
iron for each other
I don't think earlier was I yeah no no
it's okay
there was a point where because it has
to be signed for I was gonna ask Jen to
pretend to be me but it's some of our
neighbors genuinely think I'm Jen
sometimes especially if I have Portillo
with me they will have conversations
with me where they think I'm Jen
but I think I'm passing in passing like
relatively short girl similar glasses
similar hair natural yeah yeah
she's her hair's a little bit longer
than mine right now
I think mine is darker I'm just gonna
message her and ask her to be in the
package inventory management yeah you
gotta do that inventory management my
dude Salvage get rid of that fishing rod
pause the class I'm up in range to your
position oh my god oh my god I've got a
venom glaze hello
I love it's so cool I also got a
harvester I think I might download
Diablo it would be better than this
Diablo I mean this is fun but now I've
got the itch for this kind of game okay
what is the harvest run reduce harvester
releases souls in an explosion okay no
donation weight from Louie because this
says $75 it says huge thank you to my
303 favorite people in games of media
for being a tag team or was honest Alana
and I go way back in time and Lucy are
equally badass my wife is it might be so
this my wife is immunocompromised so
this gives me a chance to help love all
three of you all that you do all that
you stand for thank you so much Louie
thanks me Louie's been donating
frequently read appreciated yeah legend
all right up to date
ready to roll whatever you guys are
ready what do you start up concerning it
from platform yeah we realized when we
started this game up we were all ready
to go and then we couldn't find each
other because I was on PC and they were
on xbox so I guess this game is not
cross play or play anywhere so yeah I
had to start from the very start which
is a huge bummer but you know it's fine
that's yeah you know it's not like I'm
taking minecraft dungeons that seriously
just didn't expect it I would have
expected this game to be cross play it's
where they didn't do that
Andrew donations are going to direct
relief which is basically supporting
hospitals to deal with covet but also
going to black lives matter I split
between yeah we found we found a page
that just shows us with all the
contributions from black lives matter
okay I'm gonna rattle through a few of
these real quick let's go Bryan Ruiz
thank you so much for donating $25 Ian
minute donated $25 twice it seems thank
you so much in Nicholas Gregorio donate
$25 Julia Scott donate $50 I think that
might be one of ours yeah maybe
Nicolas rock downloaded and $25
downloaded $25 don't don't download
money friends Kyle Johnson donated $100
Chris Wargo $20 our very own Richie
Bracken want a fifty one dollars and
then Nicholas I think this is Nicholas
Rock again but he spelled his own
name wrong and done it as Nikhil ad-rock
which I'm yeah that's the right I
respect that yeah thank you so much
everyone or you're all those donations I
just mentioned now are going directly
towards black lives matter and as you'll
see at the bottom of the screen there's
two links there one is for black lives
matter the other one is for direct
relief if you donate to directly we will
still be helping black communities they
are disproportionately affected by kovat
so please donate generously or share the
stream if you can alright alright that's
pi let's jump right in
pumpkin pastures it's been signed full
sometimes they mock it done before it is
it's not downstairs
[Music]
mmm-hmm package drama continues package
drama can you still hear my laptop
struggling not to take off yeah but it's
faint yeah it's it's quiet yeah I mean
my name is of slides always loud fans in
that thing have no chill
yeah I've been dreaming on the edge of
buying a new gaming PC because I left
mine in London my for a whole baby has
to stay behind that kind of bring it
bring it with me yeah my younger brother
was like wall there is I'll like break
it down I'll keep it
component-wise stuff it with like
packing foam and ship it to you I was
like it's not work well well you could
just how big is it like could you wait
until the next time that you go home and
trip because I trust me transporting my
life to this country has taken me a long
time I still have stuff in Australia
it's quite a big can you see so I think
I think it's probably just bad to just
buy a new one
it's still like yeah pretty good specs
but time has moved on then
my respect for the future hurts though
it hurts it does it's being used it's
being taken care of my younger brothers
are using that true it's gone to nothing
yeah well the same in theory I mean it's
not leavening maybe no I have like I
have a gaming laptop which I can raise
on which is great like it can run things
on ultra which I've been really
impressed about but the fans are nuts on
it those laptops they have trouble I
guess it's supposed to be a lot better
if you have them plugged into power
source but yeah I mean even then they it
still keeps my PC is just very loud in
general I think it's because it's an
open case which I like yeah the fans are
really right next to me all the time
look at my wolf um Jeff I like it I like
it was like I had this pet peeve where I
took I took drama when I was installed
I'm an actor whenever I'm an actor
thank you whenever we'd come up with any
sort of like stories like play short
where ever it would be and got to like
naming the characters everyone be like
my characters cause Dave mounts called
joy on your you yeah I'm like you're
Pakistani why is your character called
Andrew what's going on whatever
something like whenever someone does
something like I've got it's cool ingame
wolf what's it called
I just named Jeff Jeff has a good
mouthfeel that sounds weird but it's a
nice way to come back get these supplies
lads if you didn't already did everybody
okay yeah we got we got coffee machine
but and say up yesterday and we named it
Calvin is a good name I'll send you a
picture of Calvin layer because he it
genuinely looks like it perfectly
represents me and my roommate because it
looks like it's in despair all the time
yesterday you just sent me the picture
of him with with no context it was it
wasn't even like hey the coffee retrived
it was just a picture of coffee machine
my picture of Calvin I am curious now
you have piqued my curiosity yeah this
is actually like I sent the picture
originally to our very own curve in
novena and he pointed out Calvin's
nature I was like why is it like this
what why does it look so scared what
screen my screen huh
yeah your camera apparently Oh
own arrived I see there there I am I
don't know what happened
oh no they kill a camera turned off by
chasity ah open my menu mistakes what
was that what was that kid you know this
isn't a boat he's a real punk to fight
there we go
Calvin Vince Calvin's on the world
temperance town again we need you to
help about 15 seconds to go 108 seconds
8 seconds oh my camera keeps turning off
which is not helpful it's really yeah
what's going on it's fine we have Oh
Luci we gotta take that of okay out as
soon as possible air owing it's almost
done yeah hold on I'm switching I'm
switching to a different camera there we
go
because it's overheating
Oh oh yeah we've had an issue with the
podcast for a while didn't we we're like
we could only film for about how before
Jake's camera which like oh he he and
Donna that's he was either a ridiculous
Canon like oh but even that shouldn't
over here all right that should be bad
welcome you see the news of the day that
it wasn't originally supposed to be
called John way but then he just kept
saying spam with an S yes John wick is
sort of a meaningless title for a film
like that and hard under marketing execs
I think it would have been like it was
like something like like one word
powerful one word bullets dog
before I saw that movie I didn't know
anything about it like nothing at all
and just based on the small rumblings of
conversations I had heard people talking
about it I assumed that it was like some
kind of body cup situation with a man
and his dog because all I ever heard was
so I assumed it was like a man and his
dog like vigilantes and fight crime
was sort of the read that I had and then
when the dog thing happened I was so
devastated I'm gonna take a minute to
read some donations Jonathan Jonathan a
man named or if it's just Jonathan a man
$100 thank you so much Daisy
donated $30 and said as someone trying
to get into a videogames industry it's
been a trying journey but thank you for
the inspiration and all the work you do
excuse my voice for breaking they're a
teenager right now it happens more
frequently than you realize an anonymous
donation $20 thank you for what you're
doing
Isaac link-16 says hi from Costa Rica
I'm glad to see my two favorite people
in games media Lana and Lucy I guess
some are is okay too
I'll take it all this helps keep up the
great work truly love your content
donate $25 sharayu King is back with
another ten dollars and says Thank You
Don
I think this Troy you good again yeah
yeah that's everyone there and then we
have Casey bruins donated $25 and then
Alessandra for the fillory also donated
$100 alessandro being our very own
Alessandra oh yeah thank you everyone
boy hey filling all these it's fine I
cleared it you guys have an easy walk
through here now I've got minutes I got
all these chickens mm-hmm that's the
thing about tick-tock now is that all
the old Viners are on there and you set
them down it's like I'm down I'm down
I'm down
oh [ __ ] oh my chat is saying that it was
originally called scorn that was what
school which makes it that makes sense
Thank You school yes there's a game
called scoring I think we ran out of
names a while ago I still can't get over
the fact that there's a game called wet
I walked in games when it came out a lot
of jazz a lot of you gonna get wet yeah
it was I think it was was it Bethesda
yes it was
the bad one no no you bad no that wasn't
them was I don't think so I could be
wrong show some money the chat wall
anything about it it was Professor
you're right
no he there I wasn't no van there was
like three games oh yeah yeah school and
B Fox animation in chat says scorn is
the H R Giger looking game that was a
the Xbox reveal
I'm super into that which I am too I
haven't seen like any gameplay of it I'm
just seeing what they show that inside
Xbox it high-rise creepy stuff look I
mean it really made me want to watch
must feel at home with all these accents
I don't think this little village very
cute got stalls and stuff horde mode
type situation we so much I'm have sold
if someone wants
I'm happy with my slave no no I don't I
occasionally someone lightning and it is
the best oh yeah all right let's get the
Evo code take them out to take them out
sting about you big jerk something
accidentally shooting arrows in the
walls I think it'll go over but it
doesn't videogames apparent I'm stuck on
the world there's a serious easy easy
this I need to know my controller
batteries are almost dying so I need to
get its get cable
honestly everything look I mean like
what's three-minute we've got there
eventually you should see some like tech
testing yesterday oh boy I had to stop
halfway through and go get at McDonald's
because it was getting stressful
hey smack as I get it
we're just testing it and I was
streaming my screen and Greg just like
message the house chat with today's
sucks
you guys got McDonald's oh I do love
McDonald's I really do I'm a big fan of
that garbage food but I got to a point
where I don't know if it's an age thing
it started making me feel very unwell
like I'll get really bad indigestion
what I'm trying to I mean okay whatever
Jess tchen but it made me super bloated
yesterday and I was like yeah this isn't
this never used to happen yep
my controller was fully charged
no do you have the elite sorry a skinned
one oh yes we went to an event like an
xbox one event a couple years ago and
they were like do you want to try out
the lab thing and make a coloreds
controller so oh yeah I made us up and I
made diva nice uh Richie's in the games
but Chet just said all right Lucy what's
your McDonald's order I'm also curious
about this uh yesterday I got 10
McNuggets which I think the medium meal
yeah in a diet coke and some eyes chips
because I'm pretty delicious nauseous
yeah
the end of that whoo-hoo when I was at
uni you could get the like the 99p menu
but you would also get a free
cheeseburger or a felt a fish if you
were student and you had a very specific
student card so on a now we just
absolutely rinse the McDonald's saver
menu I'm going out
yeah wasn't that with oh my god I got I
got cleaned up they're really funny rose
oh thank you I appreciate your service
call about filet-o-fish yeah time
remember we went to the one in Paris and
it was the most miserable experience
I hope yeah it was a Sunday night before
Paris games room and it was before it
was a Sunday night and it was a mall
that was pretty much closed and we went
in and I think we were maybe like one of
the last orders of the day everyone was
really done and then we just asked any
but it was like the food was bad - yeah
it was like the saddest filet-o-fish
I've ever had and filet openers are
usually joyful creations
absolutely like McDonald's that I felt
was bad like I don't doubt that it
exists but it's always exactly the same
one was stale and like yeah no no I'm so
I can be a major problem
oh boy Krispy buttermilk chicken
sandwiches that I they have in the u.s.
I don't know if they have the most going
on in this area
chastity asks what I actually have - oh
my god oh yeah it's it's very explosive
out here famed whites and I've had this
like it was like a big kind of flight
I don't know how to describe it also
chicken and mayo just a large rap thing
these delicious I get the chicken
quesadilla cheesy cheesy prep stuff
exploding in calories
I now have all back oh I died again I'm
so sorry I actually I actually have the
Taco Bell I love it I absolutely love it
I love the noise which especially funny
to me because I've never actually been
inside of a Taco Bell so I've never
heard that noise before nor have I ever
seen a talked about so it's like I'm
very so that noise doesn't really mean
anything so I find it extra funny but I
have a taco bell x-1 we had to figure
out like I couldn't figure out how to
make it stop turning itself on like if I
would turn on my TV it would
automatically turn on the Xbox and so
just strange to Best Buy yeah and when
you I think it's like actively waiting
for you to switch the channel that the
Xbox is HDMI plugged into and when you
do he'll turn itself on and be like oh
hey but it's not okay
no I've not I've not had that oh no I
have a Chips Ahoy Xbox controller as
well I just love these like bad branded
Xbox much things I am again what you're
alright bro Oh what happened to me oh it
just looks like you're sleeping
I gotcha it's McDonald's is actually a
lot better in Australia they're
basically um like restaurants in
Australia so you can get like these
gourmet buggers that have served on
those like little wooden boards and
fries in a basket oh that's how they
will like Australians on eating boss
food anymore because girls so goddamn
hipster so no Australian McDonald's like
he's like classy which is really no no
like that we also have cafe it's built
into all about McDonald's like so oh
yeah yeah so yeah Australia McDowell
[Music]
Fogle's 7 1 zeros donate $20 and said
thanks to all the people I might not
feel like we're doing enough but every
little bit helps as long as we're
consistent and persistent and find
what's right we can improve Society of
your content Alanna hope you're doing
okay thank you so much for gaming donate
$100 and said we are going through a lot
it's easy to be quiet and do nothing and
comes by button glide created such as
yourselves are using your platform to
spread awareness thank you thank you
and then Georgia Briscoe $5 Matthew
Hocking I think I understand or support
towns technical difficulties thank you
very much
and then anonymous $20 and then we have
maps Ali who donated $25 and Matthew
Hawking again $10 thank you so much I
love that there are people like double
donating that's the best thank you guys
you too real MVP
you are indeed ex-nfl off yes oh yes
yeah I fell off like right on this
bridge I think that's fine too good
system I like the teleport system cool
yeah I wish it's like a little bit
faster but it's like it gives you time
to not do it but obviously I want to do
it come on it's not much else to do in
the state but I just ate that meat thing
and I did nothing
grow up Oh in the game it's like what
meat thing you can talk about something
no no no is this is this cat mine this
is following me around yeah that's how
you get yeah yeah these arches is such a
pain in the park
all right that's some cool environment
and they've ready made the most of it
minecraft to its fullest
yeah yeah those breakfasts they'll get
you
it's the minecraft way oh my god please
come back these creepers are you just
crazy bastard just thinking about it
I think I liked it but I watched it when
I was a teenager so I don't trust my own
judgement at all no maybe watching like
I don't know we watching Jay and Silent
Bob strike back the other day and as a
teenager I remember just loving that
movie and a lot of this stuff that's how
I like the time that's how I heard of
the time is from a movie and I mean my
friend backwards quote a lot of it all
the time
and wash it back now it's like oh dear
oh yeah I always wonder that with them
dony doc oh I watched it as a teenager
and loved it and thought it was the
smartest thing ever but I don't know if
I would like it as like I really you
just like have different levels of
thinking at certain points in your life
you just different stuff up you'll see
you like I really don't know like a
bunch of movies from the 80s have held
up like extremely well but then it's
like mm yeah like Princess Bride for
example timeless but then there's like
in the 2000s it just feels so rooted to
that time it's from they actually yeah
oh yeah it's probably execs wanted
it makes me wonder about like the MC
humanities how they'll feel yeah I like
10 years from now
yeah I was watching a good video I say
was it nerdwriter I don't remember who
it was I dig it out but they were like
this is why you don't see mobile phones
in game in games in movies and it's like
yeah like primarily it's because it ages
it but interesting conversations and my
would have thought like brand deals is a
goddamn cream is do we need another key
no why don't you just throw it let you
throw an arrow hit one honey
yeah throw it like you throw it out no
mobs all right plan
like we're doing alright oh my god why
did that tell me so far back what is it
telephone time yeah I'm doing it
Oh actually flaming arrows oh yeah Oh
cut off here
oh it's cuz the next key is here got it
okay see how cute these little Oh God
goddamn creepers I have wait did I lose
too much money yeah you picked it up
okay
get back here key yeah [ __ ] he is very
cute I know do you have him now oh it's
cute little bunny he tries to run away
Oh
enchanted husk we making let me take I'm
enchanted husk anxiety yeah I haven't no
I like genuinely very glad
oh the avatar came up because I have a
new morning routine I'm not a morning
person at all neither like I used to be
that I was it used to be that I was a
real night owl but now I'm asleep by
10:30 11:00 but nothing all
I I don't know how I did it I think just
oh but also maybe just um but now I'm
waking earlier
I'm just watching a couple episodes
avatar just really real nice my dad my
son uh yeah I always like to think that
I could be a human who could wake up
early and like do yoga but never happens
yeah mm-hmm
when I was a kid one Christmas this is
one of my mom's favorite stories and I
hear it every year is that she woke me
up on Christmas Day at like 9:00 a.m.
and she's like come on it's Christmas
you know get presents everything and I
just went hmm
I went back to sleep yeah with me real
sleepy human good stuff eat fire arrows
jokes that got stressful real fast okay
here we go yeah we did it we got a $25
donation from anonymous says great cause
let's get some more donations yeah let's
do that thank you so much
and then $25 from Tori
thank you for thank you to all the help
putting this together and to support
contributing to these two important
causes Thank You Adam $10 thank you so
much and then we've got yeah I'll say
Matthew Hawking I think I've done
another $10 donation thank you you're
trying to get like the little emote menu
up and I keep accidentally opening the
menu Oh corrupted beacon fires a
high-powered beam that continuously down
just most cool I wish the artifacts
weren't so dang expensive
all right six pose em you know
salvage them bows oh my god I've got
like 350 em all right look at me
finally I finally have useful healing
stuff so that's good I so I get healed I
think if I travel a certain distance
yeah another one - alright ok let's go
to the Red Sox we got a $10 donation
from Adam a hundred dollar donation from
Henry 25 from foggy bear says keep
fighting a good fight 20 dollars from an
anonymous as well
thank you thank you so much spider if
you would like to you can turn into
Direct Relief we are also raising money
to support hospitals to deal with curb
it so feel free to donate to that yeah
thanks a bitly /gs
- BLM for black lives matter and
bitterly /gs - Kovach for direct belief
there's also a link for it in my
description as well so it's right there
I keep moving on what I hope I'm not
screwing up the way that this stream
looks my camera is exploding I'm
literally vanished for a few minutes so
I think it's overheating I'm I'm I just
open my window next time
that's so weird dude I fully didn't know
that was the thing that the cameras ever
struggle with crazy stuff oh by the way
what oh god what do they run your own
yeah they won't put you on your ass so
what now
wait time you mean the Sony camera the
Isles on yes the one is the same one
good do you see that this bread ring
that I join will heal you if you stand
in the image oh just like blown yo dog
up
I'm really sorry my god that was like a
very dramatic way across the screen I'll
get him I'll get him back he's he's
taking it all right yeah someone in my
chat asks are there any stories of IGN
buses GameSpot rivalries it's not really
a thing generally everyone is okay no
especially it's really a to literally
all of the games media are just friends
it's a yeah sieve drama I feel like it
happens like maybe occasionally with
like sales deals but the editorial teams
on at all associated with that I feel
like it happened in the 90s yeah maybe
yeah maybe not now it's I mean watch
with IGN UK and ah kg everyday so our
only rival reads oh I got hit also
seemed like it was a thing when people
are trying to like dominate the gaming
space but like no it's not really a
thing I will hang out together actually
hear whispers of things like people
trying to get like a sudden puss and
rather than the other side but like in
terms of the actual dog even that's not
a direct rivalry it doesn't matter that
it's game
my Jan it's just like what you want this
person explicitly but yeah actual people
there's no beef at all everyone's just
buds
yeah and it's like not just and like
going beyond internet again like it
sends the most other gaming brands that
you probably are familiar yeah like we
were friends with everyone at this PC
game and maybe I think you just come to
the factory every particular line of
work
hmm everyone's the same events everyone
sees each other yeah under the same
circumstances and you have that shared
love of video games and so you don't
know naturally people like probably
underestimate is we really do just
together still just only talk about
video games it's not like you're out a
walker ban with like all these people in
games media and you're talking about
politics or whatever it literally always
video games that's all it really wants
to talk about all consuming oh yeah by
the way you got uni-beam I don't know
what it's called
great keep it up we're doing it for six
weeks six weeks six whole weeks yeah so
I think the only time we won't have a
charity stream will be if there's a
publisher event that's kind of happening
at the same time so don't look and yeah
don't cover the news yeah yeah cuz
playful is it's basically like our what
our III coverage would be but also the
charity drive too so it's all just under
mobile I guess but we have some really
cool guests
it's not included but like we've got
some cool stuff planned Tam chastity and
I been booking those but mostly it's
like it's a kind of nice excuse just to
get your friends involved guess we like
thought we would never get and they've
been like a big poster by it but I don't
know if you're familiar with the podcast
last podcast on the Left I part of it
yeah yeah so it's like this horror slash
true crime podcast and we've got that
one which is a wild situation for us as
fans oh yeah do they also like are
involved in video game stuff they are
kind of like one of them as some Marcus
Fox is one of them and he's he's big
into games he's going to be doing a solo
stream of Dark Souls and then gonna have
one of the other guys Henry and Marcus
on board and we're gonna play umberto
mystery game and obviously because the
course is all about analyzing serial
killers and true crime they're gonna
we're gonna let them kind of guide guide
the decision-making process how good
they are
I'm reviving oh why did it stop the
animation stuff can you can you cover me
get that no that was really weird I like
London and immediately died it happens
I'm awesome
yeah born into an arrow and something I
suppose don't meet its gonna crossbows
on me or whatever they are cultists
maybe I don't know I don't know what
these deeper about oh it wasn't filling
them up with the bad guys might be the
bad guy we are new well building it was
what do you think was me healing you the
minecart then immediately killed you
[Music]
half an hour left
you can donate this is a charity stream
links are in the description of all of
the things the way you can donate to
Direct Relief which is helping please do
that nobody walk we
yeah yeah I've had a bet with Craig but
yes the one of these III I will get the
phrase super fun blast-off in like just
seemingly randomly and I can never it I
did of it's because like my kids and I
come frame oh god oh god oh god my host
brain like just won't let me do it but
this year not on this stream I don't got
him down
not on the stream or what we'll do it
that said so glad to see a lot of piss
back on YouTube even if it's just for a
bit great clothes by the way I never
left I mean families my last fun house
video when I'm living today but thank
you either way oh he's so mean
dammit dammit dammit dammit didn't
realize it's really hard to see the lava
yeah like so I try about people about
you falling in but I was like you have
fallen
it's not as 50 dollar donation from Ryan
please and then your hundred dollar
donation from Sandman mage Mako
megataiga
$10 and sir black lives matter and then
we've got 25 dollars from Alexandra
friends hey thank you so much Grayson
what's up thank it what time help that
boss was surprisingly intense yeah boy
boss is all pretty I respect it they uh
they don't make him too easy
hmm okay
that's pretty cool I've tweeted that
picture of Calvin looking sad I kind of
did a lot of inventory management the
last times I'm pretty much I'm gonna do
the damage the Thunder thing that I
think you have yeah static oh yes this
is baby supposed to look like you're
calling it absolutely thank you thank
you Kevin I also miss being on IGN
podcast I keep telling them to have me
but they're like one of the owners my
life has become a series of podcasts so
I feel like I do like for a week at this
point and it's a lot trying to pace that
out a lot of talking
I like the there's an old Russell Brand
quote where it's my life is a series of
embarrassing incidents punctuated by me
telling people about those embarrassing
incidents that's why I feel like my life
all right I'm just on all levels except
physical there I'm tick-tock now I found
them the other day and they did the guy
way it came up and I don't know why you
did at some point start talking about
picked up I think I mentioned like it's
like I find sure yeah I think one of us
probably got a divine look at all these
chickens
if I got your damn I wish no I don't
know I am I think two years older than
you okay
who knows yes but there's no way to find
out I'm 20 famous Beth I'm 28 perfect
have you seen those weird profiles that
people make of you like on like
birthdays uh-huh one of them had one my
net worth there's over a million dollars
okay no I do I do he's uh you need a
budget so you know my my playstation 5
yeah that's one of the reasons I haven't
made the decision to buy that gaming PC
from like this is the year only new
consoles like Friday but everyone thinks
to which should you have it always on
the Internet I was gonna try and get
from the office like we have a bunch of
old PC cases and like the tech graveyard
and so I was like maybe I could save
some money and take an old case but I
think at this point I just decided I was
like I'm just not gonna build a PC yet
of weight fast
um someone's asking in the chat like do
we have tick-tock I have it like you
need someone ever posted video hotel no
it's good content interesting you sent
me a draft it's mostly just to figure
that out and see how people make
we had a sponsored thing so I did have
to use it for fun house for a little bit
but no I don't we have a group thread
well if there's a lot like our house
group thread is just me and Jen sending
tic TOCs while Greg is just sat in the
middle of it but me Tom and Carly have a
thread it's always nice that you can I
can tell what point of the night roll in
when we all just start sending tic TOCs
to each other it's clearly like the
in-between times of when you stopped
playing whatever game you're doing or
watching whatever you're watching and
then you don't want to go to bed just
yet so you talk yeah spend all that time
just sitting on our phones watching
memes like the garbage pizza really
ready for me basically I've read it all
the time but oh yeah check trucks that
outlet now probably more lighthearted
than ready like a red it can be you cut
all over the just watching there are
some things I still like on reddit but I
just don't I use this question yeah
gaming Scottish Twitter
[Music]
my [ __ ] sister
oh it's called corrupted beacon tight
whoa
Matthew hooking says forget takes of
Portillo on cameo whatsoever doesn't
sweet old boy one time and Joey was
looking off their apartment so I went
over there and we watched Harry Potter
and called it the Pattillo my favorite
thing he does I'll come off my room oh
come on he's doping isn't he yeah I'll
come out my room and he'll run towards
me because he thinks I have food and
then he'll kind of get close enough so
that you can see me and then he just
like last minute just dodges off in the
other direction because he's like hey
he's going he doesn't know what's going
on I was having a dog thinking about it
I yeah I was looking at them not even
saying that the other day I was like oh
what is just yeah
Oh guys I guess we didn't realize I said
SEP 4 2014
I mean subs a huge anime fan
oh we've iced the man of culture yeah a
man of culture damn it I got down to gun
myself far away also yeah for the record
if you both res it doesn't go any pasta
so it's best it's not have one pulse and
res any other houses like which sucks
it's like a couple like mechanics like
that I wish they did Ariana but it's you
know it's not that serious
I get it it's baby yep those exploding
polls show bow to Siobhan ski which says
as a black video game player here to do
what I can as my donation
blacklivesmatter thank you so much and
then Katherine donate $100 yeah dude
Oh sick stupid Green Arrow's I love the
little noise they may get rekt hey oh oh
just making sure that's enough anime in
this stream better nothing at seven cama
coming back next week to do a very
special LIVE edition of Skyrim mods like
top 5 Skye wrote a week let me ask Amy I
thought playing this on controlling it
having played on PC is did the
controller vibrates so much constant
oh thank you I am I leveled up so yeah
Wheatley wasted it they following me ma
you control vibrate that time what was
that that's it's uh it's powerful delete
this column is just on my case
yeah where is where not even oh I don't
know my people are near the entrance oh
okay keep working on the objective who
the go on this year didn't know cuz I
watched a man
[Music]
Ilan she mad Oh Oh Lucien Tomas staying
in San Francisco going home before
quarantine comes in next week next week
wait what we've been quarantined for
traveling time yeah thank you
no it's Dana yeah we were supposed to be
the last week yeah friends getting
friend of mine was getting married
it was my niece's first birthday oh oh
thank you and but yeah I just rearranged
my flight yeah yeah some friends getting
married this weekend which was like I
wouldn't be able to go anyway because
III but um it says it relaxed a bit in
the UK from Monday yeah but it's weird
because it's still like stage or five or
something it seems like people are a
little bit mad though like it's relaxed
more than it should have
by this point or something I'm not
really sure I haven't
yes yeah I mean not to get political but
it's been all over the bloody place in
that quite that's a fair political take
I think it's been all over the bloody
place hasn't it yeah I mean I'm
fortunately my oh yeah my family have
been very good about staying indoors
anything I like her Randy's popped in a
conscious thing love this game I really
do hammer is very large yeah but it's
not even that good I didn't get I got
the power though yeah you get to print
stuff I think it's like sort of
randomized hundred games go for damn
alright alright nice what's it what's it
I was gonna remind people that we are
raising money in aid of black lives now
and Direct Relief who are supporting
Corvette relief efforts with health care
workers and both links on the screen and
head over today if you can
every any amount is valuable and please
do share the stream out we're gonna be
doing this for six weeks
and I'll be super helpful for both
causes if you could contribute yeah
please do oh yeah well I guess one
minute yeah
whoa yeah this game is very good for
this bet this at an overwatch with I'm a
dollar donation from drilling thank you
so much thank you yeah thank you
everyone thank you we appreciate you
hello oh oh my god oh my god i excitedly
went through a divorce I'm fine but I
don't you have to go back is you guys in
there hello okay this is the last one
watch out it's gonna do the noise and
stuff control it's powerful it's the
power of the Xbox one X controller if
the Elite Series - yeah I don't mean
they just out very good controllers yeah
I'm a huge fan yeah the weight of it is
just really nice
yeah the grip I know a lot of people
have issues with the elite looks like
that grips peeling off but I've been
using this thing but a doesn't haven't
had any of that but maybe I just been
lucky
that was quick we clean that up another
giant hammer yeah Oh powerful I keep in
Elma yeah it does sound like over there
like I'm still here come out let me eat
sign for it along punchy boy stop that
bad move did I get hit and cancel the
animation
we're dropping the TNT
what role is some maps to thumbstick
thumbstick eh
yeah it's unlikely right yeah oh is it
oh you're right it is weird I don't know
just strange choices for don't button
but I guess everything else map to
something I could have done why really
changing it up chained to the formula
keep it as well this area is really big
I'm on fire at the exact same time Oh
odd sound being streamed this someone
said that else cocky it might just be a
sound effect in the game that sounds
like this maybe yeah alright I think
we're almost done at this level which
should like
get outta here you stupid [ __ ] ads
stupid maid you owe me that sounds like
in the wall yeah you are a dog doing a
great job all good to go ma'am Bob big
hammer
put our circle down if anyone needs it
dead sure he's here he's here
hello they're reloading
I want to play tomorrow and you played
it a few weeks ago some friends of ours
but they've turned it into a nightmare
with Maude sort of thing yeah I've done
that do it so good like so many ways it
the cotton it was obvious oh yeah could
be
it's just yeah I think it's an American
thing yeah I'm gonna leave a tentative
boys please calm down all right I'm
gonna race thank you oh honey [ __ ]
sorry I just what water a little likeyou
character was in the tree just body
blocking the damage oh so good to worry
about hey Johnny
destroyed it was like three hours of the
face so they keep locking me in stupid
I'm not locked in here with you oh my
god
[Music]
[Music]
oh I got no health the same explosions
took us out oh my god thank you alright
I knees on me I'll get you those pesky
tiny zombies there we go let us out of
here I don't know if there is another
boss here but maybe there is but I guess
because we already did the Golem twice
twice yeah we have right yeah we did we
did it twice no I think Oh No yeah this
is the boss you just have to walk around
nope okay you go if you just come around
yeah all right
there we go he's so big he's so mad
climb to agree yoga nice stretch just
stretching out it is really really is
hot yoga at least he's really slowed
yeah oh oh oh we can do that yeah we can
do this what are these all about yeah
that increased difficulty significantly
yeah ask unfortunately it's all right
just tiny little squares we can take
them we can take them
probably also be large and mad alright
Peabody Rd Rustom pizza come on really
ah what's going serious note you with
donations yeah
alright so we've got a twenty dollar
donation from anonymous Thank You Toby
give $20 Ronny Petterson gave $50 novo
gave it's the dollars that was it was
like glitched out for a second and Ali
Hoff gave $20 along with the message
that was just like a heart so thank you
so much ollie
and then we got $10 from Richard gallant
read we are raising money in aid of
black lives matter and you can see the
donation link down below alewife
force there she is - BLM and then we're
also raising money for covered relief
efforts and you can see the donation
link there our wire force - yes -
covered please donate generously or as
much as it or as little as you can
every bit helps and please do try and
raise some awareness around both issues
and share the link to our tweets and
streams about the stuff that we're doing
someone might be able to
watch and help along if you can't
yourself yeah
alright good call yeah I want to pick
you so much for joining us and helping
us raise money you welcome people exam
you guys I'm on all of the Internet as
Charla Mossad it's just my name in the
middle of chars on you won't remember
how to spell it it's fine like and when
I was acting like it's chars off but
that's just a lot in the middle of it it
doesn't feel all right
thank you for joining us today and thank
you again to Ilana we'll be back again
tomorrow with some folks from min/max
easy allies game ranks and kind of funny
to do some back of the box trivia so
please join us and help us raise some
more money donation links still on
screen but we'll be tweeting them out
all the time anyway thank you again see
you next time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]